إذا قررت يوما ما
أن تخوض حربا،
فلا تخضها ضد شخص مجنون،
لا تلعب مع المجنون،
ولا تمازحه،
وحري بك أيضا أن لا تعاديه....
أصحاب العيون الضيقة
يتسابقون للتحالف مع بوتين
لإسقاط الكيان الأمريكي
الزعيم الكوري  الشمالي
متحالف مع الصين
والصين متحالفة مع روسيا،
وهؤلاء الثلاثة يحملون البغضاء لأمريكا
بسبب سياساتها ضدهم،
وهنا قد تنضم إيران للحلف الثلاثي
ليصبح حلفاً رباعياً مدمرا،
فجميعهم يبحثون عن مصالحهم،
ومصالحهم تكون ضد أمريكا
على طول الخط،
فكل دولة  منهم لديها ثأر تريد أخذه
من الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية...
كيم جونغ يريد مسح أمريكا من الخارطة
لوقوفها إلى صف جارته الجنوبية،
والولايات المتحدة الأمريكية تضع طلبا
في الأمم المتحدة
لفرض عقوبات على كوريا الشمالية،
لكن الصين وروسيا تعرقلان الأمر،
فهل هو زمن التحالف الشرق آسيوي مع الروس؟
وهل حان لكوريا الشمالية أن ترد دينها لروسيا؟
....
(التحالف مع المجنون)
...
بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي عام ١٩٩١
، تقلصت العلاقات مع كوريا الشمالية بشكل كبير،
حينها اتجهت كوريا إلى الصين
كحليف رئيسي لها،
لكن العلاقة بين كوريا وروسيا
بالرغم من ركودها إلا أنها ظلت أفضل بكثير
من علاقات كوريا مع معظم دول العالم،
إلى أن جاء العام ٢٠١٤،
حين ألغى الرئيس الروسي بوتين
معظم ديون كوريا الشمالية لروسيا،
مبديا حسن نيته لكسب حليف جديد،،
فهل الأزمة الحالية لروسيا
هي المناسبة لرد الدين من طرف كيم جونغ؟
كوريا الشمالية تمتلك أسلحة نووية
وصواريخ بالستية بعيدة المدى،
وتمتلك كيم جونغ أون (الملقب بالمجنون) أيضا،
ألا يكفي ذلك لتستأنف تجارب أسلحتها النووية؟
كيم جونغ(المجنون)
استأنف تجاربه ومناوراته الصاروخية،
بإطلاقه صاروخين بالستين من نوع كروز،
باتجاه المياه الإقليمية اليابانية،
وهي خامس تجربة تقوم بها كوريا الشمالية
لأسلحتها النووية خلال شهر واحد،
ولكن اليابان حليف استراتيجي لأمريكا،
يأتي هذا قبيل فترة قصيرة من إقامة الألعاب الأولمبية
في اليابان، فما هي فاعلة أمريكا للدفاع عن حليفها؟
وهل ستكتفي بالتنديد كما هي العادة؟
بعد هذا التصعيد وضعت أمريكا طلبا للأمم المتحدة
لفرض عقوبات جديدة على كوريا الشمالية،
لكن الصين وروسيا عرقلتا هذا الطلب،
لتقف الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
في موقف لا تحسد عليه!!!
أما هذا (المجنون) فهو يلوح
أنه يستطيع محو أمريكا بضغطة زر واحدة،
إذا ما قررت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
خوض حرب ضد كوريا الشمالية
فقد تستخدم كوريا قنبلتها الكهرومغناطيسية
التي ستمحو تكنولوجيا أمريكا
من على وجه الأرض،
بل أن إطلاقها يعني تهديدا
بمحو سكان أمريكا أيضا،،،
هذه القوة اليوم صارت في صف روسيا،
فهل تغزو روسيا أوكرانيا
مسندة ظهرها لبلاد كيم جونغ؟
...
(الصين الحليف الدائم)
التحالف الصيني مع روسيا ليس وليد اللحظة،
فهذا التحالف هو شوكة في حلق
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
حتى أن تصريحات أمريكية صدرت مؤخرا تقول،
"التّحالف الروسي الصيني خَطٌّ أحمر،
وستمنع الولايات المتحدة قيامه مهما كان الثّمن”.
وهنا بدأ الاتحاد الأوروبي  يشعر بالخطر
من هذا التحالف
فقرر فرض عُقوبات اقتصاديّة ودبلوماسيّة
على الصّين في الأيّام القليلة الماضية،
فضلا عن حملة إعلامية مشتركة مع أمريكا،
للتشهير بانتهاكات الصين ضد مسلمي الإيجور!!!
الصين التي تقول التقارير بامتلاكها
٥٠٠٠ رأس نووية،
وهو رقم مقارب لما تمتلكه أمريكا،
كما تمتلك قوة جوية تتألف من
أفضل وأقوى الطائرات منها نسخ مقلدة
للطائرات الأمريكية، ستقف بكل ما أوتيت
من قوة بجانب الحليف الروسي،
ما يسهل على الروس خوض غزوهم لأوكرانيا..
وهنا لا ننسى حليف آسيوي آخر لروسيا
وهي إيران، التي تعتبر من ألد أعداء أمريكا،،
فمن هي الدول التي سترغب بالتحالف مع أمريكا
إذا علمت أن هذه الدول الأربع متحالفة مع بعضها؟
التّحالف الرّباعي
الصيني الروسي الإيراني الكوري الشمالي الجديد،
والمفتوح لضمّ دول أُخرى،
بدأ يتبلور عمليًّا، ويُشكّل نواة لحلف جديد
قوي ومدعوم اقتصاديًّا وعسكريًّا،
ليَقِف بصَلابةٍ في مُواجهة حلف النّاتو
الذي أكل عليه الدهر وشرب،
وهنا سيتم تغيير جذري في مراكز القِوى عالميًّا.
فكيف ستكون نهاية هذه الأزمة العالمية ؟